une autre manifestation aujourd'hui à
lannion en bretagne et celle des
salariés de nokia le fabricant de
téléphones mobiles veut supprimer 400
lui postes en france entre 3500 selon la
police et 5000 personnes selon la cfdt
ont manifesté en fin de matinée avec
cette mobilisation locale qui précède
une manifestation prévue à paris
mercredi 8 juillet l'intersyndicale
espère que la direction retire à son
plan de licenciements et pour en parler
jean françois schmitt délégué syndical
cftc
nokia nous a rejoint jean françois st
jean françois schmitt merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct sur ft france
alors dans une région qui était présenté
comme la silicon valley bretonne
l'annoncé de nokia est un nouveau coup
dur que réclamez-vous au groupe
finlandais aujourd'hui on réclame tout
simplement l'arrêt du de ce plan social
en fait puisqu'il n'est absolument pas
justifiée puisque tous en fête
aujourd'hui les chiffres ce qu'on prend
les chiffres économiques sont bons
c'était vraiment un effet d'aubaine à la
fédé coronavirus pour eux pour en fait
passer ce plan au travers de badens dans
l'ambiance générale de des plans sociaux
donc ça permet en fait de fait de faire
discrètement en fait des délocalisations
ce que ce que ce que nokia toujours prêt
en fait prévu de faire en fait depuis le
le rachat d'alcatel-lucent ainsi à 4 ans
en fait ils veulent se désengager de la
france donc nous on proteste contre ça y
est on est on veut à tout prix empêcher
ça et que et que le nokia conserve son
activité en france comme il s'est engagé
à le faire auprès de monsieur macron
quand ils ont effectué leurs achats
alors est ce que vous vous estimez
lâcher aujourd'hui par les pouvoirs
publics a on le rappelle vous le
rappeliez même à l'instant que c'est
emmanuel macron qui avait validé le
rachat d'alcatel lucent en 2015 afin de
pérenniser les emplois justement en fait
le problème qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
que côté en fait des élus locaux tout le
monde est mobilisé mais on a
l'impression que tout s'arrête au niveau
du gouvernement
certes le gouvernement de ne nous écoute
pas on a l'impression de ne pas être
entendus du gouvernement et en plus
c'est très compliqué dans le contexte
actuel parce que nous sommes en train de
changer de patron au niveau de nokia
c'est à dire que le pdg l'ancien pdg est
aux abonnés absents
le nouveau n'est pas encore en place
arrivera le premier route donc c'est
très compliqué je pense pour le
gouvernement de trouver un interlocuteur
au niveau de nos cas et on n'a pas
l'impression non plus que le cas une
volonté en fait du gouvernement français
de dialoguer avec nokia et d'essayer de
faire quelque chose aujourd'hui les
discussions qu'on a sont au point mort
on a en fait dans le côté des gens côté
gouvernement qui veulent aménager ce
plan social alors que la position au
niveau de la bretagne et au niveau de
même de tous les élus locaux c'est de
stopper ce plan qui n'est absolument pas
justifiée on a un désaccord entre le
gouvernement et les élus locaux et
aujourd'hui nous ce qu'on réclame c'est
l'arrêt de ce plan est justement avec la
nomination de jean castex qui a affiché
on le disait sa volonté de mettre en
place un plan de relance pour les cultes
pour l'économie est-ce que ça suscite un
peu d'espoir pour vous on demande à voir
parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui
effectivement nous fait beaucoup de
promesses en nouant nous on nous dit on
va faire des deux on va se mobiliser
pour faire des choses mais on ne voit
rien de concret aujourd'hui on verra
demain on a un cs centrale demain avec
avec la direction
on va voir s'il y aura eu des avancées
en fait s'ils vont nous proposer des
actes des avancées mais aujourd'hui en
est au point mort depuis l'annnonce du
plan on a absolument aucune avancée donc
e peut-être que monsieur monsieur castex
ou d'autres personnes pourront
pourrons-nous nous amener des progressé
par rapport à ça mais aujourd'hui nous
on est on est en attente et on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui rien plus
rien ne se passa par le fait qu on reste
mobilisés pour empêcher ce plan social
quels seraient les moyens de pression
selon vous du gouvernement justement sur
nos cas aujourd'hui nokia beaucoup de
contrats en france ils ont localisé les
quatre opérateurs français ont signé
pour la 5g en france il ya eu des
engagements qui sont toujours ne
toujours toujours pas complètement tenus
les à des activités cybersécurité et qui
était promise à lannion ne sont toujours
pas arrivés
donc rien que déjà rappelé nokia à ses
engagements et au fait qu'il n'a pas
complètement tenu ses engagements et qui
est qu il faut qu ils les tiennent déjà
ça sera déjà un fort moyen de pression
parce que aujourd'hui nokia ne tient pas
absolument pas sa parole alors une
manifestation est également prévue à
paris ce mercredi qu'elles sont de votre
côté vos moyens d'action pour empêcher
ces suppressions de postes nous avons
mobilisé en fait un train spécial de
lannion pour venir à paris
nous attendons plus de 400 personnes de
lannion qui vont venir avec nous pour
cette manifestation à paris et donc nous
espérons être le plus nombreux possible
pour stopper en fait ce plan nous allons
manifester devant l'ambassade de
finlande
nous allons apporter en fait tous les
laits produits en fait tous les tout ce
qu'ont toutes nos badges nos qui a que
nous allons ont déversé compte devant
l'ambassade de finlande en protestation
contre ce plan social
merci beaucoup jean-françois suite
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes délégué syndical
cfe cgc
nokia